[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was
last friday at this time albert brier
senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist for the mmqb joined us and he
dropped a little nugget that he thought
matthew stafford
could get traded before the super bowl
and i go wait a minute you must know
something
and i thought let's have albert breer on
to take a victory lap
albert congratulations so what did you
know and
when did you know it you know i i think
basically i i knew that things had
heated up and that the lines were of a
mind to move them before the super bowl
in large part to get ahead of the market
and i think this was sort of smart dan
and that
you know they recognized that things
could get chaotic with quarterbacks over
the next couple of months we've all
talked about that
and is desean watson going to become
available is sam darnold going to become
available
and so i think their logic was like
let's put this guy out there so we don't
have to worry about supply and demand
screwing up
an asset and you know let's give the kid
stafford let's give him some some
certainty let's give the other team
that's trading for him some certainty
and let's maximize the value of what we
have and so
i think you know from that standpoint it
was smart to do it because
i you know a team like the rams other
teams involved washington carolina
you know they they had an opportunity to
go after a guy
who i think most teams view as a top 10
quarterback
um without you know the i'd without
without any certainty that
that anybody of that level is going to
be available again during the off season
so
yeah i think it was just sort of a smart
read of what might happen the next
couple of months
by the lions but to make this deal
happen
the lions had to take jared goff
if this was teddy bridgewater and
carolina were they going to have to take
teddy bridgewater was this
yeah was this the formula by these other
teams that you're going to have to take
our quarterback
uh if we're going to make this happen
yeah so i think it's sort of a two-way
thing dan like i i think on one hand
you're right like the
the rams were going to have to offload
goff it wasn't going to work if they
couldn't offload goff
and um it would have been tough to move
goff
if quite quite honestly it would have
been very difficult to move gough if
you know if they had traded for stafford
had both on the roster so
the the cleanest thing for them to do
was to offload golf as part of the deal
that said i mean i can tell you this
like dan campbell had communicated to
people in that front office
that he didn't want to be up a creek at
quarterback like he wanted a guy
who he could at least at least compete
with for the next few years
and so you know i think from that
standpoint
golf was sort of attractive to him and
that they had you know he has
you know almost five years um of
starting experience
you know started half his rook a year
and has been a starter since then
he started in a super bowl and um yeah i
mean i think that because of that
like there was a level of interest in
gotham that
at the very least you know he can be a
competent starting quarterback for you
for the next two or three years
and buy you time to find whoever your
long-term answer is
i think from the same you know by you
know by in the same sort of way
if you're trading with carolina
obviously teddy bridgewater would be a
guy that you'd mention if you're trading
with denver drew lock would be a guy
that would come up so
i think with you know a number of these
teams a quarterback could have come in
play
if those teams have been able to get to
the sort of draft pick comp that the the
rams are willing to give up
what's the downside for both of these
teams
so the downside for the lions is that
the rams could be really good over the
next couple of years and those picks
might not be all that valuable
um you know i think if you if you look
at what the what was in front of the
lions
they had an opportunity to get the
eighth pick in the draft um as part of a
pick swap i think they probably could
have wound up with a ninth pick too with
denver now they would have had to send a
pick back
which devalues it a little bit they
could have had the 19th pick
washington's pick and so part of the
risk for the lions here is you don't
know what's going to happen to the picks
in 2022 and 2023
and if the rams are really good you know
then those might be de facto second
round picks
so that's the risk for the lions and
doing this deal this way
the risk for the rams is that you know
they've
become very very top-heavy in their
salary structure
and there's questions about whether or
not you can put the right sort of
support system around
matthew stafford um you know obviously
they're a little bit
you know they've they've had their
issues in the offensive line the last
couple of years
how does andrew whitworth hang out hold
on hold up at left tackle
um you know what happens if one of their
big salary guys has an injury so
because of the way they're structured
now it leaves them in a position where
they're gonna have to hit on a lot of
you know third fourth fifth round picks
in order to make up the difference and
build depth in case they do lose some of
the hot
the big name guys they have and they've
been pretty good though
yeah they have you know they've done
well from the second round on
so we're talking albert breer the uh
senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist for the mmqb
is the hall that the lions got in any
way
related to what it's going to cost to
get to sean watson
no because well i think part of the hall
the the lions were able to get was
taking on goff's contract
right like so there was a little bit of
and again like the lions wanted goff
like the lions
like the idea of having goth as their
starting quarterback at least as a
placeholder
but there was an nba element to this
right like that you know they had to
the the rams had to give a little bit
more to get the lions to take on goff's
contract so
uh that definitely exists um
shoot i i lost my train of thought there
dan what was the question the the texans
and what it's yeah i i don't i do not
think it i i don't think it affects that
much i mean deshaun watson's a 25 year
old superstar quarterback
like i think you start with three
first-round picks probably
if you're talking about dealing for
deshaun watson and again we don't know
if he's going to be available
i mean right now i can tell you where it
stands desean watson isn't returning the
texans calls
and like the texans are basically
stonewalling anybody who comes
to them inquiring about watson so i mean
right now we're sort of in this giant
staring contest and
and nobody really knows what the
conclusion is
i mean because we don't know whether or
not desean watson is going to acquiesce
and eventually talk to the texans people
and we don't know if the texans are
going to get to a point down the line
where they say you know what
we got a first year coach a first-year
gm we can't start a program with this
hanging over our head for the next six
months
yeah it's kind of interesting i know
that nick casario said they're not
you know trading him or whatever no
intentions
but i if i was in the press conference i
would have followed up by
asking are you taking phone calls though
yeah because that's what i want to know
i mean you can
of course you're going to say we have no
interest in trading him um
and then see if somebody really wants
desean watson what they're going to give
up
did the rams think that aaron rodgers
was really in play
well i mean the rams so i like i think
the rams explored the idea watson too
like i think the rams were sort of
looking at all of their options as
okay how do we upgrade the position and
i think part of it was that they felt
like there was a little bit of a ceiling
there
with jared goff and you know they feel
like they're in
a championship window number one defense
in the nfl
and you know a bunch of star players who
are right in the heart of their prime
guys like jalen ramsey and aaron donald
and so you know this is sort of their
time to go and maximize what they have
so like i don't think that they felt
like aaron rodgers was available
but you know this is a team that sort of
investigates everything you know what i
mean dan like so
i you know they didn't want to be
kicking themselves on the other end of
the staffer deal
you know and they find out a month later
that rogers was available or that watson
was available
so they definitely kicked tires on those
sorts of things
to make sure okay like you know we know
the landscape now we're going to go
forward with matthew stafford as our
target
i was told last night by a source that
the lions said to matthew stafford
pick a soft landing you know that that
that we
we don't want a disgruntled former
detroit lion because we have enough of
those our star players who
haven't always been happy that that san
francisco was really in play but then i
didn't know what was going to happen to
jimmy garoppolo was that a similar
situation
that garoppolo was going to go to
detroit so like
my understanding is and this was the
understanding a bunch of teams that were
involved have
was that the top three for stafford
number one la
number two san francisco number three
indianapolis and
of those three los angeles showed by far
the most interest
um you know the the niners my
understanding is they talked to
to to the um they talked to the lions at
the senior bowl
and things escalated fast
and like i don't think that the niners
were ever going to offer the 12th pick
now they were willing to put together an
offer
but i don't think they were ever going
to offer the 12th pick and really
you know i think that their idea was
okay like let's regroup over the weekend
and you know we'll we'll put something
in front of the lions
on monday and then when the lions came
back to them after things had
escalated a little bit on saturday now
all of a sudden it was like
you know what the return was going to be
for stafford they were like whoa
you know like that's a little bit
further than we were willing to go
so i think it was sort of a combination
with the niners of
how quickly things escalated in the
negotiation friday and saturday
and then also just you know the fact
that like they're okay with where
they're at with jimmy garoppolo
and it the quarterback switched there
wasn't worth the 12th overall pick to
them
what do you expect to happen this week
if anything
hearing as far as more trades anything
anything um now i don't think that i
don't think we're going to have ac i
don't think we're going to have as much
action this week
um you know although i do think you know
you you look at some of the
like pieces of this trade and i think
you get a window
into what could happen over the next you
know couple of months and so
i do think you'll start to see some of
those exploratory phone calls
look teams are going to continue calling
deshaun calling the texans onto sean
watson
until deshaun watson shows up and puts
on a texans helmet and wears a texas
jersey again so do you think
jacksonville entertains phone calls for
the number one overall pick
no okay no i but i'll i'll give you a
give you one though like like
you know i think the number two overall
pick suddenly becomes really fascinating
i mean
i can tell you one of the teams that
checked in on stafford was the new york
jets
and i i don't think that they were gonna
go
where the rams went but you know what
that is dan i mean
a couple other teams like that was sort
of a smoke signal to them
like okay like if you're making a call
on matthew stafford does
by you know deductive reasoning here
does that mean you're moving on from sam
darnold
and if you're moving on something from
some if you could be moving on from sam
darnold
now do i put together an offer you know
what i mean or do i
see what maybe you're willing to do with
him so
yeah i i think that there are certain
parts of the staffer deal that could
lead to other things and
again the texans are naturally going to
get calls on watson
but now that some other teams that need
quarterbacks may want a young
quarterback
see the jets pick up the phone and call
the lions if you're one of those teams
do you pick up the phone and call the
jets
about darnold i just think it's
fascinating and that of course plays
into the second overall pick now where
the jets looking
at zach wilson or justin fields there
that's where all of the moving parts
with this
are going to be so interesting over the
next couple of months oh
always great to talk to you thank you
again and uh congrats on your victory
lap there albert have a great week
awesome thanks dan i appreciate it
that's albert breer the uh
nfl insider mmqb senior nfl
reporter